une arène des compétiteurs et des
moutons au coeur du salon voici henri 19
ans sélectionnés en amont aux épreuves
régionales
le jeune homme est venu de touraine
participer à ce prestigieux concours ce
quelque chose déjà qui est plutôt sympa
à vivre les gens sont super gentils
c'est agréable d'être avec les animaux
et puis
c'est sympa de venir a par ailleurs
représenté la région
parmi les épreuves l'entretien des
sabots du mouton un exercice qui
nécessite beaucoup de technique faut
être précis dans ses gestes c'est
vraiment pour nous éviter de faire mal à
la brebis tout en les faisant
correctement les biens et les dynamiques
qui s'applique il essaye de bien vrai
c'est vrai qu'il a une brebis guetté par
toute simple avec les papes
c'est bien simple hic le concours
national du meilleur berger de france
est organisé pour la 13e fois au salon
international de l'agriculture
une épreuve très importante et
l'objectif est évident c'est de susciter
des vocations pour assurer un challenge
important pour la production ovine qui
est le renouvellement des générations
pour qu'on puisse renouveler 61 % des
éleveurs qui vont partir à la retraite
dans les dix années à venir
il faut qu'on ait un creuset de
vocations dans lequel on va pouvoir
puiser des jeunes ou des moins jeunes
nous retrouvons henry pour lui
participer à la finale est une chance et
le jeune homme pense déjà à l'avenir
plus tard je souhaiterais l'installer
donc principalement bâche allaitantes
mais pourquoi pas les moutons vous que
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut pas
beaucoup de places sont agréables à
travailler avec au salon la filière
ovine se donne donc en spectacle est
mise clairement sur la nouvelle
génération